[Music]
therapy is the number one reason why
I've become a better human with my
friends outside the business world when
I'm in the business world I understand
humans I listen more I actually take the
time to understand it's a game changer
our company is midday squares we created
the first functional chocolate bar we
basically took a chocolate bar that
meets a protein bar and gets rid of the
junk that's in protein bars we focused
on people that are working people that
want something cleaner don't want high
sugar don't want palm oil want clean
ingredients and still want the
Indulgence from chocolate I'm actually
allergic to my product which is whack
but chocolate is a 140 billion dollar
industry every year and I felt like it
hasn't been disrupted over the last 50
years it's been the same companies
dominating it so when we had this like
Runway where we realized that there was
this pull for the for the market we
realized that wow we could actually
potentially become a new age chocolate
conglomerate my title is Chief Rainmaker
and why it's called that is because I
make the chocolate rain but not actually
I bring in a bunch of different
relationships whether that be investors
buyers retail buyers journalists to the
network but I do it in a very
interesting way instead of doing so
corporate which a lot of people treat
relationships like I make friends first
and then do business later and when my
sales team needs something they call me
that like I need this buyer from XYZ
company I'll make sure I build a
relationship with that person and then
bring them to them
when we started my sister my
brother-in-law and I had my partnership
we agreed to seeing a therapist every
single week so once a week at minimum in
good or bad times and we are committed
and we have gone every week since last
four years and I feel like that's built
us as very strong communicators and
leaders and to work and understand human
behavior me and my sister we're close
like you know you don't want to ruin
that relationship but yet you still need
to know when to have those hard
conversations with our criticism or
things like that where it's not coming
from my sister it's coming from my
business partner
foreign
I've worked really hard on myself for
that reason and then you know making
sure that I also know where my partners
are at all times in life like are they
going through a bound time are they on
enough time do I not bring something up
to them because I understand the context
we have signs like peace signs or
something on the heart where I know how
someone's feeling before I could bring
something up that has actually allowed
us to set ourselves apart to understand
have empathy like things that a lot of
leaders in today's world I think need
more of we focused on that and now we
bring some of our teammates into it so
it creates a culture that's extremely
different where the the human is the
priority people first then everything
else
we've raised to date
17.5 million private and then about 4
million from government so the
government has lent us to build our
Factory everything else 17.5 has come
from growth Capital so from Venture
funds in the U.S or year one we did
about a million dollar sales uh year two
we grew to about three you're three we
did about nine and then this year we're
likely to close at about 17 to 18.
our fundraising Journey has been a lot
easier I would say than our peers in the
space and the reason why I say that is
because we show everything on social
media on LinkedIn on tick tock on
Instagram Facebook and the idea behind
that is to show the transparency of who
we are as a company and what we're doing
so whether that's hardships so failures
we've had or huge successes or in the
middle of stuff that gives the investor
the know who who we are so they already
know who we are when we meet so they're
like we love you or hate you one of the
other and that's allowed us to get in
touch with all types of investors from
different Industries and then choose who
we want as investors
I think that has challenged the cpg
world to kind of take storytelling to a
very different level and basically guide
it where it's no longer about okay just
the product features of the product
let's talk about how it's vegan
gluten-free soy free non-GMO that's
great that should be table Stakes but
now you're talking about okay this is
who the company is that's where the
consumer feels wow I could become a fan
rather than just a customer
[Music]
I'm excited to show the world that you
could continue to win at whatever you're
doing whether you're a pilot you know
you're on a Chocolate Company by being
yourself I think if we continue to
follow our gut every single day and and
and stay true to that and keep winning
then we can Inspire the Next Generation
to go out and do the same thing and stay
true and be proud of who you are
find your superpower who is yourself and
embrace it and engage it and I think
that that's what I'm most proud of to
date and I hope I can continue that
foreign
[Music]